KILLED.
AND TONIGHT, THE PRESSURE ON HIM
REMAINS INTENSE.
TONIGHT, CNN LEARNED OF A CLOSE
CALL FOR THE WORLD'S MOST WANTED
TERRORIST.
A MAN WITH A $10 MILLION BOUNTY
ON HIS HEAD.
ISIS LEADER AL BAGHDADI.
A SENIOR U.S. MILITARY OFFICIAL
TELLS CNN U.S. SPECIAL
OPERATIONS FORCES CAME "CLOSE TO
CAPTURING OR KILLING BAGHDADI IN
MAY OF LAST YEAR NEAR RAQQAH,
SYRIA."
>> THE SOONER THE BETTER.
>> Reporter: THE U.S. MILITARY
OFFICIAL SAID WHEN U.S. FORCES
RAIDED A COMPOUND LAST YEAR AND
KILLED AN ISIS OPERATIVE, THAT
TERRORIST'S WIFE, WHO WAS
CAPTURED, TOLD THEM THEY HAD
BEEN WITH BAGHDADI A FEW DAYS
EARLIER IN RAQQAH.
>> SHE WAS THE DEN MOTHER FOR A
LOT OF THE SEX SLAVES, THE
YAZIDI GIRLS AND KAYLA MUELLER,
THE WESTERN HOSTAGE.
SHE WAS BAGHDADI'S PERSONAL SEX
SLAVE.
HE WAS RAPING HER.
THAT WAS THE LOCATION WHERE THE
U.S. SPECIAL FORCES RAIDED.
>> Reporter: WHERE IS BAGHDADI
NOW?
EARLIER THIS YEAR, U.S.
OFFICIALS SAID HE WAS MOST
LIKELY HIDING IN RAQQAH, THE
ISIS STRONGHOLD.
AT SOME POINT HE'S BELIEVED TO
HAVE GONE TO MOSUL, IRAQ.
BUT IRAQI SOURCES TELL CNN JUST
AFTER THE IRAQI OFFENSIVE BEGAN
IN OCTOBER, BAGHDADI IS BELIEVED
TO HAVE LEFT MOSUL, DESPITE
RECORDING THIS AUDIO MESSAGE FOR
HIS FIGHTERS.
>> Translator: HOLDING YOUR
GROUND IN HONOR IS 1,000 TIMES
BETTER THAN RETREATING IN
DISGRACE.
>> Reporter: OFFICIALS TELL CNN
BAGHDADI'S DAYS ARE NUMBERED,
BUT TONIGHT HE REMAINS ELUSIVE.
HOW GOOD IS HE AT EVADING
DETECTION?
>> HE TAKES IT TO A WHOLE NEW
LEVEL IF YOU LOOK AT THE WAY HE
APPROACHES OPERATIONAL SECURITY.
THE AMOUNT OF INFORMATION THAT
WE HAVE ABOUT HIM COMPARED TO
SOMEBODY LIKE BIN LADEN IS MUCH
THINNER.
>> THE RUMORS THAT THIS IS THE
GUY WHO USED TO COVER HIS FACE,
EVEN WHEN MEETING WITH SOME OF
HIS OWN PEOPLE, SOMEONE WHO TOOK
EXTRAORDINARY PRECAUTIONS WHEN
IT CAME TO HIS OWN SECURITY.
>> Reporter: AND THAT LIKELY
ALSO APPLIES TO HOW BAGHDADI
COMMUNICATES.
TONIGHT, A U.S. INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIAL TELLS CNN BAGHDADI AND
HIS LIEUTENANTS UNDERSTAND THAT
ANY LEVEL OF